-Performing "Hills,"
from his Grammy-nominated album
"Third Time's the Charm," please
welcome Jamaican reggae star
Protoje and his band
Indiggnation!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Gabbing up, yeah ♪
♪ Smoking up, yeah ♪
♪ Beaming up, steaming up
chiefing up, yeah ♪
♪ Gabbing up, yeah ♪
♪ Smoking up, yeah ♪
♪ Beaming up, chiefing up
steaming up, yeah ♪
Reporting to you live
from Irishtown, Jamaica.
Oh, yes, oh yes, man.
Reggae music is forever.
Jamaicans are here.
Let's go.
♪ Whoo, whoo ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di
hills yuh know ♪
♪ Like hide away,
no sign a me ♪
♪ Steam up three time a day ♪
♪ Find my way ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di
hills yuh know ♪
♪ I get my privacy,
like, finally ♪
♪ No bad vibes inside a me,
in my domain ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna
di hills yuh know ♪
♪ Like hide away,
no sign a me ♪
♪ Steam up three time a day,
find my way ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna
di hills yuh know ♪
♪ I get my privacy
and mind mi business ♪
♪ They talking,
I ain't listening ♪
♪ Aye, fresh air inna morning ♪
♪ Six mile fi di day
despite gravity ♪
♪ Everybody just smile when dem
witness hail up di artist ♪
♪ Gwaan, hold yuh fitness ♪
♪ But me stay inna
mi business always ♪
♪ Better live life
simple nowadays ♪
♪ Caw people find a way ♪
♪ Fi try yuh patience,
I evade dem, zoned in ♪
♪ Deeper in dis moment ♪
♪ Look at these surroundings ♪
♪ All that's given oh the Earth,
she loves her children ♪
♪ Fresh fruit from di garden,
eh ♪
♪ Herb grow pon
di mountainside ♪
♪ Can I tell you,
when I'm up dis high ♪
♪ Touch di sky ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di
hills yuh know ♪
♪ Like hide away,
no sign a me ♪
♪ Steam up three time a day ♪
♪ Find my way ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di
hills yuh know ♪
♪ I get my privacy,
like, finally ♪
♪ No bad vibes inside a me,
in my domain ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna
di hills yuh know ♪
♪ Like hide away,
no sign a me ♪
♪ Steam up three time a day,
find my way ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna
di hills yuh know ♪
♪ I get my privacy
and mind mi business ♪
♪ They talking,
I ain't listening ♪
♪ If you don't see me
inna while, smile ♪
♪ Don't be surprised ♪
♪ Tell them ♪
♪ Caw when me wake
inna morning ♪
♪ I can't deal with di noise ♪
♪ Yeng, yeng ♪
♪ Better you come link me ♪
♪ We don't sit inna traffic ♪
♪ Jelly water from di tree ♪
♪ All now it nuh reach ♪
♪ Inna plastic, it drastic ♪
♪ Smoke from di car,
dem a kill me ♪
♪ Too much apartment building ♪
♪ Every day,
ten more kiln them ♪
♪ That's no life
for the children ♪
♪ Fresh water flow
from stream ♪
♪ Everybody start moving
just like whoo, whoo ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di
hills yuh know ♪
♪ Like hide away,
no sign a me ♪
♪ Steam up three time a day ♪
♪ Find my way ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di
hills yuh know ♪
♪ I get my privacy,
like, finally ♪
♪ No bad vibes inside a me,
in my domain ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna
di hills yuh know ♪
♪ Like hide away,
no sign a me ♪
♪ Steam up three time a day,
find my way ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna
di hills yuh know ♪
♪ I get my privacy
and mind mi business ♪
♪ They talking,
I ain't listening ♪
♪ Whoo, whoo ♪
♪ Gabbing up, yeah ♪
♪ Smoking up, yeah ♪
♪ Beaming up, steaming up,
chiefing up, yeah ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna ♪
♪ Eh, how ya been,
how ya been ♪
This one's for Don Duck.
Rest in peace, my G.
Jo Mersa Marley, eh.
♪ Whoo, whoo whoo ♪
♪ Man, I been up inna di hills,
up inna di hills, yeah ♪
♪ Up inna di hills, yeah,
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]